- Le théâtre d'art drde Marioupu
le théâtre d'un hore e e drame
sous l'impact d'une bombe.
par le média en ligne
bélarusse Nexta, des résidents
de Marioupol s'y abritaient
russe a niée l'attribuant
d d d des groupes nationaliste.
Selon les autorités locales,
des milliers de civils ont
assiégée réduite à néant depuis.
Ceux qui ont pu fuirse réfugien.
Dans cette arène de cirque,
ils ont trouvé le répi n n n n ,
des vêtements chauds.
Avant que sa maison à Marioupol
ne s'effondre, Dmitry avait
passé une dizaine de jours au
théâtre deuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiu.
Daria raconte les bombardements
ince
Elle dit avoir passé 10
assise avec son enfant dans
les bras, dans le sous-sol
Autre ville, autre drame,
une dizaine de corps gisant
ukrainien Suspline News,
ils ont été touchés par
des éclats d'obus alors
qu'ils faisaient la
pour avoir du pain.
Une information que l'armée
américaine à Kiev confirme sur
Twitter.
un mur d'école à Kharkiv,
comme un p      à
la guerre. Deux écoles
ont été touchées par
Ce résident de la ville
ramaatatatatatat d'obus.
"Ce sont des cadeaux des Russes
pour libérer le peuple
à feu et à sang.
"Il y avait plusieurs
Boum boum boum,
puis le feu s'es,,,,,,
raconte cet homme.vivivivivivivs
et qui a blessé des pompiers.
C'est toute l'Ukraine qui
s'est réveillée sous les bombes.
La capitale, qui observe
un couvre-feu jusqu'à demain
n'a pas été épargnée.
Les secouristes s s s s s s s st
les survivants.
Comme le fait le Présidentleleln
avec le maire de Melitopol,
Ivan Federov, enlevé paré.é.é.é.
Au bout du fil, le Maire
remercie le président Zelensky
de ne pas l'avoir abandonntrtrt.
Si sur le terrain, les combats
font rage, la cause de l
a été entendue à la Cour
ine e e e e e e e justice,
le plus haut tribunal
à Moscou de suspendre
immédiatement ses opérations
militaires en Ukraine.
Radio-Canada, Montréal.